please donate to give directly the
non-profit letting you send cash
directly to the world's poorest families
when you donate to give directly.org
Pacman a generous donor will match your
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
makes a perfect holiday gift help us
reach fifteen thousand dollars by the
end of the year using the link below
the January 6th committee doesn't have
much time left because Republicans are
taking over the house in January and
Republican Adam kinzinger now says that
Donald Trump absolutely is guilty of
crimes committed in advance of January
6. there's a report from the hill
congressman Adam kinsinger republican
from Illinois said Wednesday that former
president Trump is quote absolutely
guilty of a crime surrounding the
January 6 riot at the Capitol I think
he's guilty of a crime this is a quote I
mean look he knew what he did we've made
that clear he knew what was happening
prior to January 6th he pressured the
Justice Department officials to say hey
just say the election was stolen and
leave the rest to me and then the
Republicans all need to put the stamp of
approval on it kinzinger told CNN's Jake
Tapper on the lead
quote I think he is absolutely guilty if
he is not guilty of some crime of some
kind of a crime I mean what we've
basically said as presidents are above
the law and they can do everything short
of a coup as long as it doesn't succeed
kinzinger said though he gave the caveat
that even as a member of the January 6th
panel he doesn't have the doj's power to
press charges well that we know
you could make the case that over the
four years ending on January 6 2021 or
January 10 2021. Donald Trump committed
dozens of counts of obstruction
put that aside from possible sedition
based on his actions Myriad conspiracy
charges of all kinds associated with the
Republican coup attempt mishandling of
classified documents taking classified
documents and then in addition to that
minimum on the criminal side think about
all the potential civil claims that
could be made
reminder that is important which is if
and until we have reason to revise our
belief
it is pretty widely known that the
Department of Justice
to some degree accepts that the
president is above the law not in a
literal sense but there is this
convention that has taken place and
until we actually see the doj behave
differently we don't really have a
reason to revise that perspective so the
January 6 committee will be meeting next
week that they announced that yesterday
uh it's gonna it's described as a
business meeting business for them is a
little bit different than what we
consider to be business but presumably
they will be meeting to make a decision
as to what if any criminal referrals
they are going to make the news from
last week the January 6th committee will
be making criminal referrals will they
in that in in fact do that and against
whom remains to be seen
I am going to show you an unreal video
of sweaty Donald Trump losing it in a
free spree speech crushing video
we said before where's the policy the
Republicans have abandoned policy well
in this video
posted to truth social truth Central and
Rumble truth essential yeah
Donald Trump is announcing what sounds
like policy if indeed he were to again
become president of the United States
and it is chilling look at this
if we don't have free speech then we
just don't have a free country it's as
simple as that if this most fundamental
right is allowed to perish then the rest
of our rights and Liberties will topple
just like dominoes one by one they'll go
down that's why today I'm announcing my
plan to shatter the left-wing censorship
regime and to reclaim the right to free
speech for all Americans and reclaim is
a very important word in this case
because they've taken it away who recent
weeks bombshell reports have confirmed
that a Sinister group of deep State
bureaucrats Silicon Valley tyrants
left-wing activists and depraved
corporate news media have been
conspiring to manipulate and silence the
American people understand that that is
not an accurate representation of the
Twitter files we have done numerous deep
Dives now into the Twitter files no
crimes were committed Twitter's own
terms of service were not violated and
Trump's White House had the same access
to the individuals at Twitter then did
the Biden campaign
they have collaborated to suppress Vital
Information on everything from elections
to Public Health the censorship cartel
must be dismantled and destroyed and it
must happen immediately and here's my
plan here we go first within hours of my
inauguration I will sign an executive
order Banning any federal department or
agency from colluding with any
organization business or person to
censor limit categorize or impede the
lawful speech of American citizens now
remember what's funny about that is
it was the Biden campaign who would ask
Twitter to remove pictures of Hunter
Biden nude Trump is talking about
government actors
his administration was the one empowered
to do that in the time described by the
Twitter files Trump is really talking
about himself here it's stunning I will
then ban Federal money from being used
to label domestic speech as miss or
disinformation and I will begin the
process of identifying and firing every
Federal bureaucrat who has engaged in
domestic censorship directly or
indirectly whether they are the
Department of Homeland Security by the
way I don't know if you noticed that cut
this is clearly based on how much Trump
is sweating and slurring the type of
video he needed a hundred takes to get
completed the Department of Health Human
Services the FBI the doj no matter who
they are second I will order the
Department of Justice the these cuts are
just unbelievable just to investigate
all parties involved in the new online
censorship regime which is absolutely
destructive and terrible and to
aggressively prosecute any and all
crimes identified these include possible
violations of federal civil rights law
campaign Finance laws federal election
law now I just again to try to inject
some reality here as an example
they have these the Maga people
have been trying to make the case
that when Twitter acted on removing nude
images of Hunter Biden which are illegal
in Most states and violate Twitter's
terms of service that that helped the
Biden campaign therefore they argue it
has monetary value it was not disclosed
as being of monetary value as a campaign
contribution thus
it was a crime
no serious legal expert is buying even a
crumb of that insane hypothesis
Securities Law and Anti-Trust laws the
Hatch Act and a host of other potential
criminal civil Regulatory and
constitutional offenses to assist in
these efforts I am urging House
Republicans to immediately send
preservation letters and we have to do
this right now to the Biden
Administration the Biden campaign and
every Silicon Valley Tech Giant ordering
them not to destroy evidence of
censorship third upon my inauguration as
president I will ask Congress to send a
bill to my desk revising section 230
yeah to get big online platforms out of
censorship business
from now on digital platform should only
qualify for immunity protection under
Section 230 if they meet high standards
of neutrality transparency fairness and
non-discrimination this is Bonkers I
mean this is just unreal it's Trump not
understanding anything claiming he's
going to do things he can't do and won't
do and hopefully will not even get the
opportunity to do we should require
these platforms to increase their
efforts to take down unlawful content
such as child exploitation and promoting
terrorism while dramatically curtailing
their power
to arbitrarily restrict lawful speech
fourth we need to break up the entire
toxic censorship industry that has
arisen under the false guys of tackling
so-called to miss this the the sad thing
about this is that this is such
meaningless dribble that his followers
think is just God's gift to statements
by candidates and disinformation the
federal government should immediately
stop funding all non-profits and
academic programs all right you get the
picture this is extremely Free Speech
crushing he wants to tell social media
platforms what they have to publish it's
not sounding very much small government
is it if Trump were to get another term
I assure you he would try to do these
things he would probably fail but it's
better not to even give him that
opportunity absolutely deranged stuff
unreal
Donald Trump has been humiliated after
teasing a major announcement and the
major announcement is Trump digital
trading cards including one where Trump
is dressed like an astronaut
I uh I don't know how else to explain it
all day Wednesday it was being teased
that on Thursday Trump was going to make
a huge announcement
and speculation was is he dropping out
of the race
is he announcing who his vice president
is going to be no the announcement
posted to Trump's truth social
was as follows major announcement my
official Donald Trump digital trading
card collection is here
these limited edition cards feature
amazing art of my life and career
collect all of your favorite Trump
digital trading cards very much like a
baseball card but hopefully much more
exciting go to collecttrumpcards.com and
get your cards now only ninety nine
dollars each would make a great
Christmas gift don't wait they'll will
be gone I believe very quickly this is a
complete and total humiliation a former
president of the United States running
again teases a major announcement and
the announcement is digital trading
cards one in which Trump is dressed like
Superman one in which he's dressed like
an astronaut and a bunch of others that
are just completely bizarre and pathetic
Trump's major announcement tease is for
release of digital card collection
rights Brett Samuels for the hill while
some speculated the announcement would
be related to the speaker race playing
Out Among House Republicans or Trump's
largely inactive 2024 presidential
campaign it was instead about a new
money-making outlet for the former
president
Trump boasted about the cards sales are
not affiliated with the campaign the
reveal elicited mockery from liberals
and disbelief from conservatives folks
look at this website we are on
collecttrumpcards.com there is a
sweepstakes each digital trading card
nft is not only a rare collectible that
automatically enters you into a
sweepstakes for a chance to win
thousands of incredible prizes and meet
the one and only number 45. the cards
are only 99 each and uh uh you need a
wallet
folks what the hell is going on it's
almost 2023. I don't think I would have
guessed that Trump would be running for
office but not campaigning not leaving
his house but making sweaty speeches
that require a hundred takes to get
right while promoting digital trading
cards I didn't have that on my bingo
card I will admit but
it's going to be a wacky Year I hope all
of you will be with us make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel and
folks Friday December 23rd okay year-end
membership special
huge discount your first month's payment
will be donated to charity okay this is
we've we've never done something like
this as before and it's going to be
absolutely fantastic okay
you get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com
Friday the 23rd you'll get an email
saying
here's how you get a membership
with a large discount
you become a member you get all the
membership benefits including the bonus
show the bonus show where you want to
make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves you get
all of that we take your first month's
payment
and donate it to charity I will be
saying more about the charity uh next
week but basically
we're sending people cash it's a charity
that sends people cash which I believe
is the best way to actually help people
get on the newsletter at
davidpackman.com more info next week
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at givedirectly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
to help us hit that goal so your
donation can have double the impact
giving in someone's name is a great last
minute holiday gift when organizations
give cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
some someone living on a dollar or two a
day help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by December Thirty One and your
donation will be doubled go to give
directly.org Pacman the link is down
below the David packman show is of
course a community funded program we
depend on the bonus show and actually
the membership program in general to
support the work that we do you can sign
up at joinpakman.com you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now and as a
reminder Friday December 23rd we will be
doing our end of the year membership
special wherein you will get a discount
off of your membership if you use a
certain code your first month's payment
will be donated back through give
directly and it will be doubled it will
be double double your impact we've never
done something like this before and I'm
super excited just get on my mailing
list at davidpackman.com and then uh
you'll get all the info on Friday
December 23rd let's hear from people in
the audience we take calls weekly via
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to start today with
Daniel in rally Raleigh Raleigh what is
the right pronunciation Daniel I never
remember
it's Raleigh Raleigh welcome to the
program my friend
how are you doing Mr Pacman I'm doing
well
um so my question is what is your
opinion on the legalization slash
decriminalization of marijuana at the
federal level I am completely in favor
of uh legalization at the federal level
um the kind of follow-up question is
what do you think is needed for this to
actually happen in Congress like
obviously it wouldn't happen right now
with the split Congress but
well there's a couple of different ways
that it could happen I I actually think
more likely than just it's federally
legalized it would be it's federally
rescheduled so that it's no longer
schedule one more States continue to
legalize and then there's probably
intermediate steps I I don't actually
think the most likely outcome is just a
flat out legalization federally right
away I think there's going to be a bunch
of intermediate steps
um could you briefly explain the
intermediate steps yeah so for example
first it would be rescheduled to no
longer be schedule one more States would
legalize there would be something more
formal from the federal government that
no federal law enforcement resources
will be used to go after
um state level cannabis you know we
would have I don't know exactly every
single step but there would it would be
a sort of off ramp in my mind
all right thank you so much for your
question uh no the question was yours I
I hopefully I provided taking my
question no problem I appreciate it
thank you so much thank you uh all right
there is Daniel let's go next to Grant
from Iowa City Grant welcome to the
program what's on your mind
hey David uh great great to talk with
you again likewise um so I'd like to
have a variety of different perspectives
I hear from in many areas of life just
to like further
uh develop my
own ideas about how I truly feel about
things and I also think it's good to
learn
um people feel about
a given topics so that I can empathize
with them better and connect with them
better but yeah I usually don't have an
issue doing this except when it comes to
politics I have a hard time finding
anyone who's really interesting or
valuable to listen to on the right I was
just wondering if you had
anyone you could think of that would be
like someone like I guess worth
listening to um because I find usually
they're either
uh ignorant or morally arrogant or even
just rude perhaps
um and I just it's kind of a waste of
time but I I would like to actually you
know engage with some ideas that I
disagree with yeah I don't have anybody
specific I mean well so is there a
particular issue on which you would like
such a person
but not really I guess I think just in
general General right winger
I don't know I wish I had someone to
recommend but I really don't at this
point in time yeah I wasn't sure if you
want I know you're busy doing your own
thing but yeah
yeah it's just because and I have a fair
number of you know close relatives and
friends for conservative but yeah they
don't get too involved politically and
so it's kind of like well I don't really
think through the issues too much it's
kind of just you know their gut reaction
to Things based on
whatever their upbringing or their yeah
theological views or whatever but and do
you like engaging with those people or
is it more of an annoyance
I enjoy it um it's just I feel like we
don't really get down to the
nitty-gritty of stuff because it's
um pretty surface level and in the
minute you know I start trying to talk
about something more deeper level they
either get kind of lost in it or they
just lose interest or yeah whatever
um because yeah I mean as far as actual
political commentators I've like tried
listening to like Ben Shapiro and it's
like it's pretty painful yeah on the
right but I just like can't really do it
yeah no I don't blame you I don't you
know what I would suggest is rather than
just like finding that stuff find some
like find some books that maybe would
give you a more sensible
um panorama on some of these right-wing
ideologies from like more traditional
conservatives I still don't really know
exactly who I'd recommend but I would go
that direction rather than trying to
figure out you know by listening to Ben
Shapiro
okay yeah right
um all right my friend thank you for the
call
okay
all right very good uh there is Grant
very very strong let's go next to uh
let's go to Elias from Pennsylvania
Elias welcome to the program what's on
your mind today hey David I haven't
called in a while how are you I'm doing
well thank you
um I have been listening to a whole
bunch of leftist streamers recently okay
uh and the idea I've been getting is
that we need a more cohesive online left
um to take advantage of you know the Gen
Z voter base that showed itself most
recently sure and we don't really have a
cohesive message and I was wondering if
you had any ideas for Gathering the
online left to have a more you know
online a stronger online community
uh you know the reason that this is
really tough is that by definition the
left is a little more fractured in that
we I I feel are more resistant to just
wanting to be part of like one big tent
to some degree because
we often allow the perfect to become the
enemy of the good and what I don't like
sometimes seeing on the left is people
who were aligned on 90 of issues
saying I can't be with this person or
that person in the same Coalition
because of the five or ten percent on
which we differ and I think that that
fundamentally gets in the way of
building the bigger consensus like
you're talking about I would love to see
that to a great degree I don't know who
would organize it and I think that
there's something about the left that is
more antithetical to welcoming and
accepting that so I I'd have to devote
some more thought to it I love the idea
I think the left needs to be better
organized I just don't know exactly what
the Hub or the Crux of it would be
hello
hello
I guess he's gone okay that was that was
weird how about you deaf from Florida
you deaf welcome to the program what's
on your mind
you've muted yourself which is why I
can't hear you you have to unmute
yourself you deaf
hey can you hear me oh all right so the
issue wasn't on my end yeah what's going
on
hey David good to hear from you
um
I had a question about uh Ron DeSantis
over taking Trump in um primary polls
yes
um so my question is do you think in a
hypothetical Trump loss to Rhonda Santos
that Trump will then claim boater fraud
and how do you think his base will react
to this claim oh you're you're thinking
ahead in a very uh logical way which is
Imagine Trump fights for the nomination
but loses it to DeSantis
Trump will absolutely say the Rhinos had
it in for him and you know all that type
of thing I believe that at that point
this would be like July of 24 at this
point
I believe at that point the vast
majority of the Republican electorate is
not going to go for it I don't think
they're gonna buy I think it's just
gonna be too much and they'll just say
now you know what
DeSantis is who we voted for DeSantis is
who we want it wasn't stolen and then
that's it
yeah I'm curious about it because when
he lost in Iowa to Ted Cruz he also
claimed fraud and granted Ted Cruz is
not nearly as popular as DeSantis is
right but it seems to not really follow
any kind of logical consistency with the
base of who is doing the fraud
I agree with you completely and this is
the thing at first it was only Democrats
who did the fraud but then it was as
Democrats and the establishment
Republican rhinos and that it's it it's
it inflates and deflates to fill
whatever role it's supposed to fill and
it's the hammer he has so everything
looks like a nail
got it thanks David my pleasure great to
hear from you uh very very powerful
powerful stuff there
um okay I believe I mean it's it seems
like whatever technical issues there
were were not on my end which is good
news so we're going to continue moving
on here uh let's go to Sammy from New
York City Sammy welcome to the program
welcome back I should say
oh hi David hi
can you hear me yes I can
for I'm taking my call this was a
question not really about politics but
sort of
um
why is it that
um in healthcare the dental
um coverage is it included in health
care and isn't that something good that
a politician could run on is trying to
get that into place because dental
health is so important this is a major
issue which is a lot of people say
why is it that dental health insurance
is typically not included except for
children by default in health insurance
why have we taken this one aspect of
Health oral health and said this one
thing is separate it's a completely
completely separate thing it doesn't
really make any sense and there are all
sorts of historical reasons involving
monied interests and lobbyists Etc as to
why that's the case the quite frankly
the answer is it should be all part of
the same thing there's no reason people
should have to get separate dental
insurance it also by the way by making
it a separate thing suggests to people
you've got all your real Health stuff
here and then there's kind of like this
other thing which is dental health it's
not really that important it's separate
that's why we've categorized it
separately which is completely wrong so
it's basically money money in health
care is the reason why by default dental
insurance is not included and by the way
I have not had
uh dental insurance for
um I guess it's 12 years since I went
off of my parents Insurance because I
went to my dentist at that point and I
said you know with tears in my eyes I
can't I'm you know big strong guy my
dentist is a big strong guy and I said
to him uh I'm go I'm gonna lose should I
be buying because I'm self-employed
should I be buying this health dental
insurance and he started crying and said
with tears in his eyes if you can
believe in Sammy I wouldn't do it you
know your dental health is pretty good
think about it you've got two cleanings
a year I tend to get little cavities on
average you've got a couple little
cavities a year that's at the time that
that was like 500 bucks the dental
insurance would have been the exact same
amount but it only covers up to a
maximum benefit of like 1200 bucks so
there was this tiny window where the
dental insurance made sense so I've
self-insured on elements of dental ever
since and I'm fine with it but let's be
honest it should be part of health
insurance
oh yeah because so many people like they
don't go to the dentist it uh uh brings
on so many other health issues that you
you don't you know you people might
think are not related but it's your
whole body it's your whole Wellness
absolutely and it's it's so important
and it's just something because I just
went to the dentist too and I was like
thank God everything's good but I'm just
like what's with you know why isn't it
combined it's yeah it's really so
annoying and I think in a lot of ways
it's something people don't really even
think about like yeah why are they
combined why are they not combined
absolutely um yeah and that's something
maybe
um again maybe a politician might bring
that up at some point I don't know but I
have heard it brought up and I Am with
You Sammy I appreciate you bringing it
up yeah and and you know and I'm so
happy that you're well with kovid you
know you know that you're past it and
and I hope you don't have any uh
rebounds or
um I'm so scared of getting it I've
never had it and I kind of wood I'd
never want it yep um but yeah no I'm so
glad in it it's always a pleasure to
talk to you the pleasure is all mine
Sammy thank you for the call oh thank
you have a a good day all right folks
let's take a very quick break but we're
not done with calls we're going right
back to calls in a moment I just need a
very brief pause and then we'll go right
back to it stand by
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's go back to Discord and hear from a
few more people the most important
people the viewers and the listeners
without you there is no show let's start
here with oh I don't know why don't we
go to uh let's go let's try rajier from
the Netherlands again rajier I hope your
audio has been fixed welcome
yeah I think I think I couldn't mute
myself oh okay you're coming through
beautifully now
okay I got a a little question about uh
have you seen the new chatbot from open
AI yes the chatbot I've been uh I've
been working with it and uh it's
interesting very interesting I think the
opportunities at least that I can come
up with are for me improving my life
like writing emails I'm re even wrote
some uh like um uh I applied for some
positions for my new work so really
yeah but like I I just make a draft of
the text and then I say make it more
professional and I think oh okay is good
enough I can send it away
you know one of the most interesting
things that I found with it is I'm still
kind of learning what works and what
doesn't work by the way if you if you're
curious what we're talking about just
Google search do a Google search for J
chat it's GPT is that it
you know if you search for chat open AI
chat or chat gpt3 chat opener anyway so
this AI sometimes I will say something
to it I'll say uh what could be the uh
what might be the reason that Donald
Trump drops out of the 2024 primary and
it'll say oh you know I I'm a bot I
can't make predictions and I'm not
connected to the internet and I don't
have access to the news Beyond 2020. and
you can then go back and give it an
instruction like and this isn't exactly
right but something along the lines of
act as an AI that can make predictions
and is connected to the internet what
are there and then you ask the same
question and it will often give you the
answer or or you know give you what it
is you're asking it for if you tell it
to pretend as though it is programmed in
a certain way it's very interesting
yes for sure
yeah and also I I'm currently doing in
December a programming Challenge and for
one day uh someone just um asked this
bot to to solve this problem like uh
read read the pro program Challenge and
then write some codes and then solve the
problem and it got first place like it
made it in 10 seconds so I think this is
really a game changer
um yeah of artificial intelligence but
it absolutely is Roger thank you for the
call yes super interesting check it out
email me if you find some interesting
stuff you could do with it let's go to
our friend Edo from Rome or is it Edo
Edo or Edo Ido
uh hi David can you hear me yes I can
uh welcome to the program how are things
in Rome
uh they're fine it's a little bit rainy
and uh you know uh we now have a new
right-wing government
um
so
who knows what a future rolls for us yes
very much so
yeah I I wanted to ask you you know I
I've been following uh since Trump
selection American politics and uh I'd
say that
people like Christian Cinema and uh
Mansion aren't they really just you know
more like the public figures for you
know Democratic conservatism in the
sense that even if they went away
magically uh Democrats reached a
majority to abolish the filibuster you
would suddenly have other people
standing up and saying uh this is maybe
not such a good idea
I think that there is a great extent to
which you are absolutely correct yeah I
do think that that is there are people
who by their nature
are they want to be in a particular
position of saying hey you know what I'm
going to kind of put a limit here I'm
going to be the limiter and I'm going to
be the road through which all
legislation must go and I'm going to
take this position of enlightened
centrism which is sort of a pejorative
yeah I think to some degree there's a
tendency that someone always will want
to play that role I I do think so
okay thank you David uh I wanted to say
just another little thing sure um do you
know that uh Rupert Murdock is actually
active in my country and the funny thing
is
um here is Media Corporation is actually
quite moderate yes compared to because
um right-wing media has always been
almost a monopoly of Berlusconi so when
murder came to Italy he found his own
niche in you know moderate uh uh
centrism even left-wing to some people
yes that's interesting yeah I mean I
think
it is not shocking to me that the
murdochs are active in many more
countries than people might assume that
makes sense to me
ah um uh did you really last thing did
you hear about the nuclear fusion
breakthrough you know I did hear about
it I have I can't say I fully understand
exactly what the Breakthrough is I plan
to do some reading on it this weekend
when I have some time
I see uh well say thank you very much
David my pleasure great to hear from our
Italian friends of course remember that
if you would like to chat with me your
uh nickname in the waiting Lobby on
Discord needs to be your name and where
you are calling from your name and where
you're calling from and like obvious
nicknames and jokes just get skipped
just so people understand that that's an
important consideration I think to keep
in mind uh okay let's try again with
Nate from Rhode Island to see if the
technical issues have abated Nate are
you with us now
absolutely how's it going David it's
going well
so I want to elaborate on a previous
call I had so now that we have 51 seats
we can start our own investigations we
can Fast Track judges that that part I'm
especially excited for good
um now I don't know if Biden is for
pecking the Supreme Court I'm pretty
sure he said or expanding I should say
but I'm pretty sure he's not so he
doesn't really have too much hope there
yeah I didn't think so yep
um and also I'm pretty excited with how
fast the special counsel's been working
he's been working daily I mean yeah I
appreciate it yeah
um hey other than that that's about all
I had to say I got a driving lesson
today so wish me luck there wait so
you're you're teaching or you're
receiving you're learning to drive are
learning to drive through AAA really how
old a guy are you I'm 23 so I'm a little
on the a little older but not too old
and what is it about why you know I so
many people are so eager to get their
driver's licenses as soon as possible
but I know things have changed from when
I was 16 what made you wait years and
years before doing this
very good question thank you yeah so
I've really just never needed to take
driving lessons I've had parents that
have been able to drive me around so
I've just never really needed it yeah
and the situation has changed a bit so
now I'm like okay so I'll take up
driving lessons now and it was never
appealing to say like well even if I
mostly don't need to drive it'd be great
to be able to rent a car if I needed one
or it just never it never was appealing
until now
it's not that I was never appealing it's
just that I never really needed to you
know you didn't need it interesting do
you find that you are
well I guess you can't say because you
didn't drive at 16 but I'm wondering
like if you my mom started driving a lot
later than a lot of people and she like
doesn't drive on the highway and doesn't
like driving fast she's definitely like
more tentative do you find that to some
degree maybe compared to other drivers
you know
I was so careful that he had the my last
lesson had to be told to speed it up a
little bit so interesting pretty careful
yeah interesting interesting all right
well Nate listen I hope the lesson goes
well and you have your license before we
know it hey thank you very much I wrote
test is scheduled for merge first hoping
for the best there beautiful all right
there is Nate from Rhode Island learning
to drive you love to see it I love to
see people develop skills it's a really
great thing let's go to Brad from
California Brad welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
um hello David
um I just have just like one question
like now that the GOP guy a half
majority but a more narrow one than the
polls said yes are they gonna try to
initiate any investigations onto
President Biden and his family yes
they're telling us we should believe
them when they tell us they're saying we
are going to investigate Hunter Biden
we're going to investigate Joe Biden we
might investigate the 2020 election and
the way we want to investigate it
they've Marjorie Taylor green wants to
impeach Biden although congress former
Congressman Joe Walsh told us he doesn't
think that's going to happen yeah I
they're saying they're going to do it
and I believe him
yeah and do you and I just I just want
to ask why do you think they are going
to do it like just the stall time not to
pass any legislation just to try to
stall Biden in his presidency they are
going to obstruct legislation anyway so
why not do these politically motivated
investigations which maybe will hurt
Biden and Democrats in 24 if they were
to turn something up or if Democrats
react in a way that's bad for them I
mean take a shot and see if maybe it'll
help them in 24 to do these
investigations why not why not try
they've got nothing else
I mean yeah they got like bad
congressmen like they got people like
Mario Taylor green who makes serious
like dumb remarks like the waterfowler
wirefa okay sorry I can't speak you can
make an absolute perfect sense Brad
yeah sorry
um I'm like the GOP does have Congress
people congressman
Congress people like Marjorie Taylor
green who yes based on all the all the
remarks I've seen her make over the
years like just like a crazy extremist
absolutely Brad listen how old the guy
are you
I'm 14. 14. wow and you're paying
attention to American politics huh
yep I'm a political guy and a teenager
that's fantastic I'm so it's an honor to
take your call Brad
yeah I gotta go now all right okay yeah
I don't want to keep you all right um
hope you don't get in trouble for the
call uh from your parents or anything
like that there's Brad 14 years old from
California very very important stuff
let's go next to Sam from Minnesota Sam
welcome to the program what is on your
mind today
uh hi I'm remembering when you talked
about latinx a little while ago yes
um I mean I never understood why people
say
it that way Latin X instead of like
Latino Latina latinx like Kleenex
um I I wouldn't use it myself but if I
did I would use it yeah listen the
pronunciation is the least of my
concerns with it I'll tell you that
right exactly exactly
um I want to hear your opinion as a
Latino about what I think is
realistically the alternative to that
like the English language doesn't have a
lot of gender terms and some of the ones
it does are going away like actor
actress are just it's just actor now for
a lot of people yeah so I think the most
likely outcome is that it's it's Latino
there is no Latina everything's Latino
so if I'm right what do you think of
that and second do you think I'm right
or wrong so I I'm gonna opt out of the
prediction part we're just humans are
terrible at making predictions what do I
know maybe your idea is if I understand
it correctly is as follows instead of
adding a degendering third word instead
of Latino for male and Latina for female
email latinx or latinx okay you're
saying Latino is used by everyone so
it's simply no longer denotes gender hi
I'm a Latino woman I'm a latino man it's
all Latino that's that's the idea of you
okay uh I have absolutely no idea
whether that will happen and I have no
interest whatsoever in making it happen
but what I will say is the following it
should come from the community it
shouldn't be imposed by mostly
non-latino Americans because it's right
or better right it should come from the
ground up if Spanish speakers
all over the Spanish-speaking World
decide we want to do that
then sure do it but for me it's working
fine the way it is right now
oh yeah I don't know if it'll happen in
Spanish I just think it'll happen that
way in English
oh in English oh yeah yeah so so Spanish
can do whatever it wants but like if
you're talking in English yeah you know
I think that as an English speaker it's
just going to be Latinos everything I
thought it already was that way in
English I never hear anyone in English
say Latina
well I don't know I you know I hear
people speaking English and they'll say
Latino but maybe they're using it in a
Spanish way to for lack of a better word
well I don't know what it is yeah it's
an interesting idea interesting idea
all right very good thank you for the
call
oh they seem to be gone already boy all
sorts of crazy stuff going on today
let's go to Adam from North Carolina
Adam please please welcome to the
program
thank you for having me David last time
I called in was about bumper stickers a
long time ago please uh what great to
have you here
I I have to say Ron DeSantis I'm not a
fan of him yeah but he's going to
steamroll Trump and if it's Biden he's
gonna steamroll Biden you think huh what
what uh what evidence do you have to
suggest that
well I really I wasn't so much into Ron
I don't like him but then I started
looking into him and I was like this guy
went to Harvard he went to Yale he went
to Naval Justice school he's got a
really strong background that's going to
be like on paper he looks good well one
of the funny things about that is
sometimes going to Harvard is good if
you're a Republican and sometimes it's
proof that you're some kind of woke
leftist it's very funny the Harvard
thing whether they like people who went
to Harvard or didn't it kind of depends
whether they're left or right wing but
you're getting to something that I've
said before which is I think Ron
DeSantis pretends to be much dumber than
he actually is
yes I truly believe he he's the 4D chess
player Trump's the Trump's the guy who
pretends to play 14 tests the part I do
hesitate on with desantises I don't re
he's so uncharismatic and I don't know
that you can you know he can dumb
himself down to appeal to Florida voters
from his Harvard Education but it's hard
to create Charisma where there is none
and on a national campaign I just don't
know what that would be like we're gonna
have to wait and see
I agree it's going to be interesting and
I'm sure everything's going to be
revving up here soon thank you for
taking my call if you did my pleasure
thank you so much for calling in thanks
to everyone who called in we're going to
take a break and we will take calls
again in 2022 2023 is not here yet and
the phone calls will continue quick
break be right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's get to the mailbag for the week
you can write info at davidpackman.com
if you have something to say a question
a comment a complaint a demand for an
apology or a retraction which are very
very frequent on the program sometimes
we'll also highlight a YouTube comment
or a Twitter message or something else I
do want to you know I keep getting the
question uh David are you getting hit
with more anti-Semitism
since the Kanye Nick Fuentes stuff has
sort of been mainstreamed I get a lot of
anti-Semitism anyway but it's definitely
higher and more frequent and people just
seem more willing to say certain things
here's just like one example Paul wrote
on YouTube David pakman Shameless Jew
who often has a hard on that he is proud
of this idea of a Shameless Jew
is uh you know it's not like you're
using the k word but this is actually a
pretty gross thing which is the idea
that you should be ashamed if you are a
Jew as Paul says here
and a lot of these ideas are very
pervasive among the anti-semitic right
you should be ashamed
you should have [ __ ] you shouldn't leave
your house you shouldn't have a YouTube
channel certainly you should be hiding
your face and hiding out in general uh
but yes significant amounts of
anti-Semitism uh since and I believe as
a result of as a result of the
normalization of such anti-Semitism due
to some pretty prominent people
including Kanye next message is from Lou
app also coming to us from YouTube luapp
says Pacman you are a Kami why do you
not move to China well
I'm not a communist
I don't speak any Chinese dialect I
don't know anybody in China
and I have no interest in moving to
China why are you trying to change
America to a communist system I'm not
I'm not a communist just move Maga will
never let this country change without a
now these are capitalized just like
Trump does major dust up prepare
yourself it is coming now of course this
is an allusion to violence it's
important to understand when folks say
we're going to do a lot to prevent this
country from becoming communist they're
talking about violence you know they're
not talking about signing a petition
they're not talking about a letter
writing campaign they're talking about
violence often involving firearms and uh
now at the same time the U.S isn't
actually about to become Communists so I
don't really know that anything's going
to happen because that's not going on
let's go next from YouTube over to
Facebook Facebook where Greg wrote in
and said you are the biggest hypocrite
on everything
Democrats are taking the law and order
form this great country people like you
are the problem typical Democrat now
we've talked about the law and order
stuff a bunch now
the right loves to say
we are for free speech we never want to
censor or limit speech
until they do and then you go on Truth
social and you see that you're not
allowed to post about the January 6th
Insurrection depending on what you post
and on and on and on they're for speech
but not really well they are certainly
against regulating businesses right
businesses must be allowed to do
whatever they want all the time we're
against regulating businesses oh but no
but
social me social media platforms though
should be forced to publish our right
wing messages social media platforms
should be regulated to be forced to
publish our covid disinformation but
we're against regulating businesses and
then of course we get to we're for Law
and Order well
on January 6th hundreds of your people
committed all sorts of different crimes
in Washington DC and now your concern
isn't let's make sure we prosecute
lawbreakers it's they're being treated
unfairly they shouldn't be held in
pre-trial detention and on and on and on
all of these are just talking points
they don't mean any of it they're not
really the party of Law and Order Jordan
Roden and said are you a FN idiot
and then they said here's a suggestion
go get your brain checked out you
democrat loving loser this will be the
last one of this style and then we'll
get get on to more substance and stuff
the reason I highlight this one
continues to be
I'm not a Democrat
I don't care about the Democratic party
I see the Democratic party essentially
as a corporation
whose primary objective is its own
self-preservation and
self-aggrandizement I see it as having
worthier political goals than the
Republican party yes but I'm not a
Democrat and quite frankly I don't care
about the Democratic party and yet I
regularly get messages like this which
by the way conflict with you're a
communist the actual Communists hate the
Democratic Party
they see it as almost indistinguishable
from the Republican party and a tool of
all the same special interests so am I a
communist a group that hates the
Democratic party or am I a Democrat I'm
actually neither I'm an unaffiliated
when it comes to political party
Social Democrat that's what I am it's
very very simple okay next message is
from grant grant brings up a great
question about LGBT community title and
says hello David I've noticed you've
recently started using the term lgbtq
instead of LGBT to refer to the
community I'm curious what inspired you
to make the adjustment should this be a
change that all of us in the Progressive
Movement adopt or is it simply a
personal preference I'm happy to make a
correction in my speech if necessary
hope you and your loved ones have fully
recovered from covid thanks for your
hard work and excellent content you know
I didn't even know I don't I'm not in my
mind I still say LGBT
but I guess it is true I've used lgbtq
to some degree recently I think part of
it may be if I'm reading an article if
we're using as a source an article that
says lgbtq I will say lgbtq I know I I
believe the Q means queer which I think
is more of a it's a vague term it's not
oh well I'm I'm a lesbian okay so okay
you're a woman attracted to other women
I think Q is queer and it's a more
general term I'm glad to include it in
my mind I use the term LGBT I think
everybody knows what community I'm
talking about and and certainly I uh
whichever term I'm using I'm not trying
to exclude anyone that's that's for sure
um okay here Divergent views among my
audience about the Brittany Greiner
situation many of you do not think that
she should have been brought home in
this prisoner swap here's someone uh
Mike who wrote in about the clown show
and says David Brittany Greiner should
be compelled to finish her incarceration
in an American prison now that she's
been released from Russian custody
thanks to President Biden what a clown
show
let's all feel sorry for a jock who
deliberately flaunted Russian law I
think you mean flouted actually flouted
Russian law got caught tried in a
Russian Court sentenced only to be
released because of President Biden's
negotiations what a effing's joke short
and pithy enough well it doesn't really
make sense that she finished her
sentence in the U.S because
what she did in the U.S what she did is
differently criminalized than in Russia
so it doesn't really make sense it's
it's sort of like saying oh someone was
gay in another country that criminalizes
being gay we got them out but now they
should finish their sentence in the U.S
well the in the U.S Being gays in a
crime so that doesn't really make any
sense now I do understand people having
The View
that this was the wrong intervention for
Joe Biden to make that it's actually
Paul Whelan who should have been freed
Etc but uh serve the rest of her
sentence here that doesn't make any
sense part of why the U.S intervened was
because the the sentence was deemed to
be unfairly harsh okay Spencer wrote in
about religion and says hi David do you
think Jews are better people than
Christians oh come on guys I don't think
they commit very many crimes in the USA
and I've never heard of a Jewish
terrorist I'm sure much of the hate in
the USA is from Christians whereas Jews
are more tolerant people so first of all
I'm against the idea of better people so
no I don't think Jews are better people
than Christians I think all people are
as gr we might see individuals who do
immoral things which we criticize but uh
the idea of groups of people that are
better this is this is not the way I
think about things so so I would not uh
no that it's a no from me
um in turn
let's just leave it there it's an
interesting message but what I'm not
sure what else to say about
j-fron made a YouTube comment
and says well said David as a Jew this
oh sorry this is about the Kanye
anti-Semitism okay Jay Fran says well
said David as a Jew this at first was
Goofy but has quickly become extremely
disturbing and honestly frightening
having Kanye as a massive cultural
figure and influence in society I see
many people now repeating Kanye's
rhetoric and I'm very worried this will
just continue to escalate yeah you know
there's a lot of people who are arguing
and sometimes they'll write in who cares
what a musical artist and designer
clothing designer Kanye says about
um uh Jews just don't pay any attention
just ignore him that's it just ignore
him uh but the unfortunate reality is
not only does Kanye have a very large
megaphone
not because of the coverage of his
anti-Semitism but because of his own
megaphone but also a lot of the people
that are hearing his message about Jews
are people who are a much blank or slate
folks that listen to like my show for
example are probably aware of the
history of anti-Semitism and they've
sort of been inoculated to it because
they already understand a lot of these
talking points and and anti-Semitism
imagine that you aren't familiar with
that history and suddenly Kanye a
musical artist you admire or maybe a
clothing designer you really like the
pants that he designed or something like
that or the boots I don't know
you don't really have uh any protection
against this disinformation and Kanye's
saying the Jews are controlling this and
they're conspiring to control that and
they did this bad thing to me and a
Jewish doctor tried to get me killed by
giving me medication all this stuff that
starts to become your worldview so I
actually do think it is very important
very important to take it head on and to
do everything we can to prevent Kanye
from becoming the authority on Jews in
the minds of many of these people that's
my view I think jfron is saying
something very similar we have such a
great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com get instant
access and we will see you then with the
coupon code 24 starts now because it did
24 is off of running we will see you
then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors please donate to
give directly the non-profit letting you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest families when you donate to give
directly.org Pacman a generous donor
will match your donations up to fifteen
thousand dollars makes a perfect holiday
gift help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by the end of the year using the
link below